we would now like to calculate the
potential function for a universal law
of gravity so let's set up a coordinate
system first and in this case we're
going to make a very special case
although the general result doesn't
depend on that so suppose we have a
planet of radius RP and we have a small
object and initially our object is a
distance R away from the planet this is
our initial state and the planet has
mass of the planet and our small object
has mass and and this object is moving
of course orbits really aren't like that
so we should be a little bit more
careful but our orbit might be some type
of hyperbolic section conic section and
the orbit over here is at some final
position did and our eyes the distance
from the object to the center of the
planet as our final is now let's just
because there's a central point in this
problem the natural coordinate system to
use is polar coordinates in the plane
and let's just imagine that at this
moment we have the universal force of
gravity here's our object and it's being
displaced a distance s so our coordinate
system is polar
let's call R hat this way and theta hat
that way and let's blow up our little
displacement in terms of our coordinate
system just so that we see what's
happening so our displacement had a
let's imagine that our little DS vector
is pointing like this and our center
point here we have the R hat pointing
radially outward and the theta hat
pointing towards the center now to
exaggerate this picture if this is R
then the arc length here is Rd theta and
the difference
as the object moves from one point here
to a closer point towards the center
will be D R and so our D s vector we can
write as a radial piece R hat now I
don't put a sign in there because only
the endpoints of my integral will tell
me whether I was going towards the
planet or away from the planet and our D
theta theta hat and our gravitational
force is minus G mass mass of the planet
over the distance squared R hat so now
what we see is that when we take the dot
product of these two forces our hat down
our hat is one in polar coordinates why
is that the case our hat dot R hat is
one because these vectors are purpose of
the same direction the angle between
them is zero and remember that any two
vectors that are perpendicular have dot
product zero R hat and beta hat are
perpendicular and so R hat dot R hat is
1 R hat dot theta hat is 0 so we only
get minus g-m P R squared D R and that's
the first step in calculating our
potential difference because you of our
final minus you of our initial by
definition is minus the work done in
going from the initial state to the
final state which are described by these
parameters our initial in our final of F
gravitational dot d s and now we have
actually minus sign in the definition
another minus sign coming from the dot
product and let's make this our
integration variable our prime our
initial R prime equals our final and
there's going to be a third minus sign
because the integral of D RR prime
squared is minus one over R prime so
there'll be three minus signs one from
the definition one from the scalar
product and one from the integration and
so we get our final
- our initial equals three minus signs
give an overall minus sign G M and
planet one over our final minus one over
our initial so this is the change in
gravitational potential energy as my
small object goes from some initial
state to some final state what about the
potential function where should we
choose our reference point now so our
reference state here is a little bit
unusual and it will be at infinity and
we'll choose as a potential for our
reference potential to be zero at
infinity that means when our imagine an
initial state very very far away from
the planet and we'll take as a final
state an arbitrary state just where the
object is some distance R from the
planet now we have to be a little bit
careful because in this calculation are
always our final state must always be
outside the planet when the reasons for
that is subtle but the gravitational
force inside the planet is no longer
minus G m1 m2 over R squared so our
analysis only applies for our bigger
than our planet and if we put these
values for R and infinity in here we get
U of R minus the potential at our
reference point which will be 0 equals
minus g-m and P and here's the reason
why we choose that reference point 1
over our arbitrary state is just minus 1
over 1 over R but 1 over infinity if we
use the initial state as the reference
point 1 over infinity is 0 so that's
minus 0 and so what we get is that the
potential function is equal to our
reference potential plot actually minus
g-m mass of the planet over R for R
bigger than our
reference and that is the potential
function for the gravitational problem
but now remember we're choosing that to
be our reference point and so the real
conclusion is U of R equals minus g-m
and planet over R with you at infinity
equal to zero now let's just finish this
by saying in words precisely what this
means so if I start my system at
infinity and I end my system a distance
R away from the planet and I calculate
the work done by the gravitational force
in going from infinity to a distance R
away from the planet I take a minus that
sign so the negative of the
gravitational work then that's what that
number corresponds to